mais c'est un film très fantastique et
surréaliste ouais non non alors vous
allez avoir 90 ans cette année alors
depuis depuis les cannibales qui date
d'il ya dix ans vous avez tourné non
vous l'avez de gloire de commander la
divine comédie le jour du désespoir val
abraham qui est une adaptation libre de
madame bovary la cassette le couvent
partie voyage au début du monde qui est
le dernier film de marcello mastroianni
puis inquiétude qui est votre dernier
film
et puis vous êtes vous allé tourner très
bientôt une adaptation aussi très libre
moderne de la princesse de clèves c'est
tout ça c'est impressionnant c'est
stupéfiant
compte tenu alors évidente mais cela dit
quand on regarde le bilan de votre vie
on s'aperçoit que vous avez vous n'avez
jamais fait que vingt longs métrages en
70 ans alors et parce qu'évidemment vous
vous avez été tenus au silence je
suppose pendant la période de la
dictature est ce que est ce
qu'aujourd'hui avant et avant c est
pourquoi derrière pourquoi j'aime pas ça
le corps est à moi je vais j'écris
beaucoup il y avait deux scénarios de
commentaires et pour toute chose je
crise qui est qui j'arrivais à faire le
dos rond français tendrement terre parce
que mon père m'a élevée avec une petite
machine
j'ai trouvé à un ami qui a gagné tous
les concours de photos je vais inviter
ça permet de travailler dans la banque
et ne peut pas sortir que à la 24' qui
sonne alors ça c'est un ventre s'est
terminé à 31 il faut dire que j'ai bien
vous êtes le dernier c'est aujourd'hui
le dernier réalisateur en activité à
avoir connu le cinéma muet mais je me
dis quand même est-ce que tout s'est tu
cette énergie que vous avez vous avez
capitalisé pendant toutes ces années
soit parce qu'on vous vous n'aviez pas
l'argent pour faire les films soit parce
que après vous n'aviez plus la liberté
fr est-ce que cette énergie vous ne la
rassure paie pas depuis depuis 20 ans
depuis dix ans depuis 15 ans dans des
films qui s'enchaînent d'année en année
j'ai accompagné de l'évolution du cinéma
et l'évolution de ces les massais c'est
pas une chose à part de l'évolution des
choses vis dans la vie la mentalité
la solution la guerre tout sa femme sage
beaucoup c'est my même je crois
les tréteaux du tout et tous les
artistes où tout va changer nos thomas
sais j'ai accompagné sans faire et quand
je peux faire je fais vous n'avez donc
pas le deuil aujourd'hui des films que
vous n'avez pas fait a beaucoup ah bon
oui beaucoup que oui beaucoup plus que
j'ai fait
ebro bon marché et alors vous qui est de
comedia là je vais vraiment comment
expliquer que quand même c'est cette
activité fabuleuse de monsieur libéral
comment ces domaines quand même
extraordinaire souvent souvent par des
créateurs qui arrive à son âge ont une
mémoire tel tellement riche qu'elle
occulte l'imaginaire or lui son
imaginaire n'a jamais été aussi si
extraordinaire comment expliquer ça je
sais qu attendent bien un culte et je
lisais très peu mais à la fin maintenant
la la littérature ça m'étonne beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup la literie juste n'a pas
de lui avant maintenance à cette vraie
relation saine gestion alors je suis
enfin chantait de lire quelque chose je
trouve d'une phrase magnifique la loi et
après je tourne des rues étaient
désertes l actionnaire comme lionor
odorat au miel cidre son agrégateur
formidable et après je trouvais avec les
intérêts français
soulier de satin j'ai crevé avec 60 des
français et je trouvais de certains
français et jeux extraordinaires
vraiment ordinaire et extraordinaire sur
l'inné et géré monnaies mais pourquoi ce
genre manon la remontée qui ont des
d'autres
américaine que je ne sont souvent comme
cela cette année ni moi qui vais ce
encore piccoli me déprime l'ific macro
vite
et catherine deneuve très sympathique
c'est plus facile de travailler avec les
débroussailleurs je ne fais rien c'est
tout que fait bien bien